Christopher big black Boykin Zechs wife  opens up to et about his final days of  MTV  Robbie dyrdek big black oh boy big black  welcome to our crib just one day after a  rep for big black confirmed the 45 year  old had died his ex-wife Shannon Turley  opened up to et exclusively about his  life and legacy she lamented quote he  was a great father that was the best  thing about him my daughter is having a  hard time dealing with it  Turley said their nine-year-old daughter  Isis was at the hospital in Plano Texas  when big black died but added she's  surrounded by family and a lot of love  big black had struggled with heart  problems for a long time according to  his ex Turley shared that the reality  star had congestive heart failure and a  defibrillator in his chest for 10 years  funeral services are in the works  Turley says it will be a private  gathering amongst family  [Music]